uber is the godfather of ride hailing
they have 5 million drivers worldwide
and operate in 900 different cities to
put that in perspective even walmart
only has 2.3 million employees now of
course uber's employees aren't full-time
like walmart's but together uber drivers
provide ride sharing and delivery
services to 65 million people in america
alone but despite this insanely massive
network uber has never been that
profitable of a company in fact since
they went public they haven't even had a
single 12-month period in which they
were profitable for a little bit it
seemed like uber was finally turning
things around as the company posted
their first profitable quarters last
year but in 2022 things have gotten
worse than ever before as uber just
posted the worst quarterly loss ever
coming in at nearly 6 billion
as you would guess this hasn't been
great news for the stock as uber has
sold off 66 from its all-time high
coincidentally this correlates to a
market cap loss of roughly 66 billion
dollars
and while that is quite devastating it
also makes sense considering uber's
financials for uber to really make
progress forward it they have to first
become profitable so here's why uber has
been struggling to make money and when
the company might finally become
profitable
one of the biggest fundamental issues
with uber's business model is that
they're constantly fighting with
themselves to grow larger here's the
thing for uber's network to be as strong
as possible they need both the drivers
and riders to be on their side but the
issue with this is that the goals of
riders and drivers are exactly opposite
of each other riders want the service to
be as affordable as possible while
drivers want the service to be as
worthwhile as possible so uber is stuck
in this super weird catch-22 situation
if they raise pay for drivers they'll
grow the size of their network but this
is pointless because less people will
find their services appealing on the
other hand if they lower fares they'll
appeal to more customers but this is
once again pointless because there won't
be enough drivers to meet demand clearly
uber isn't quite a pickle but this isn't
that surprising when you take a look at
the history of the taxi industry
the first gas-powered taxis appeared in
new york in 1907 but it was until the
launch of the model t that this industry
really took off soon enough there were
dozens of new taxi companies fighting
for market share and there's really not
much innovation you can do with the taxi
business really there's only one way to
capture more market share and that's by
lowering fares and that's exactly what
all these companies did this trend was
just further accelerated by the great
depression as many of the people who
lost their jobs turned to becoming taxi
drivers all this competition it
completely eliminated the profitability
of the industry and we saw protests
break out across the country these
protests demanded that the government
regulate the tax industry by limiting
the number of taxis in each city and
that's exactly what the government would
do
so becoming a traditional taxi driver
isn't as easy as simply getting a car
and marketing your services you actually
have to get a taxi medallion in most
urban cities across the us
while this did make the tax industry
rather bureaucratic it also affects the
profitability problem the takeaway from
this story is that the tax industry has
never been profitable without
regulations and limitations and given
that neither uber nor any of their
competition abide by any of these
regulations thanks to a few loopholes
it's not surprising that they've been
struggling to make a profit to make
things even worse ride-hailing companies
are extremely well-funded lyft for
example currently has 4.7 billion
dollars in total assets and uber has 32
billion in total assets even with the
recent six billion loss
so for these guys it's not just a race
to the bottom it's a race to see who
will go bankrupt or get bought out first
and the survivor takes it all the bright
side for uber is that if they do make it
to the other side they'll have such
massive economies of skill that they'll
basically become untouchable but in the
meantime they're burning money as always
likely the only technology that can
disrupt uber's dominance in such a
future is robo taxis machines don't care
about getting paid a decent amount and
they rarely have to rest or take a break
so this is clearly what uber needs to
get to the next level but it can also be
used against them uber is of course well
aware of this threat and that's why
they're investing so heavily in robo
taxis but this hasn't exactly worked out
for them in fact in late 2020 uber
ditched the idea of creating their own
robo taxis by selling their robotics
division to a company called aurora now
uber did take on a stake in aurora so
it's not like they completely gave up on
robo taxis but they did limit exposure
and give up on the idea of developing an
in-house robo taxi and while this might
sound like a questionable decision at
first glance it was really the only
choice they had because they don't
really have a chance against tesla for a
couple of reasons starting with data
collection data is likely the single
most important factor in developing
machine learning and artificial
intelligence especially when it comes to
edge cases and with how many cars tesla
already has on the road collecting data
it's basically impossible to catch up to
them in terms of data
way back in april of 2020 tesla already
had a 3.3 billion autopilot miles so
they're probably closing in on 10
billion miles by now
this amount of data is simply not
something that uber can compete against
with a small fleet of test vehicles i
mean even google has only been able to
clock in 20 million miles so the odds
were never that great for uber but even
more importantly than the data lead
tesla has something that no one else has
which is that consumers are literally
paying tesla to develop autonomous
vehicles with companies like uber and
google they have to make money from
their main businesses or raise money to
invest in robo taxis but tesla already
has hundreds of thousands of customers
who are paying them at 12 000 per car to
continue developing autonomy this is
clearly not a battle that even google
much less uber can win and uber did
eventually realize this but not before
sinking 2.5 billion to europa taxis
themselves and while it makes sense why
they made this bet this bet has
unfortunately been weighing down on
uber's bottom line for years
fighting in a race to the bottom and
being forced to ditch robo taxis are
already bad enough but these issues were
just made even worse by leadership
usually when we talk about bad
leadership we're generally talking about
nba businessmen who prioritize
short-term profits over long-term
innovation
but when it comes to uber we're actually
talking about the co-founder travis
kalanick travis wasn't exactly a bad
leader from a business perspective per
se
he was expanding the company across the
globe and he was heavily investing in
self-driving which seemed like the right
move at the time the real problem with
travis however was all the drama that he
brought with him first of all travis was
infamous for overseeing a rather toxic
workplace culture
allegedly he had a bad habit of turning
a blind eye to gender-based
discrimination and harassment and in
february of 2017 a former uber employee
would publicly blast the company for
these practices this prompted a full-on
investigation into the company's
workplace culture by former u.s attorney
general eric holder eric's investigation
would result in a slur of
recommendations for uber one of which
was reducing travis's role at the
company this was already a pretty bad
situation for travis but things would
just get even worse when travis himself
would get accused of harassment as this
entire harassment case was unfolding
travis was also being blasted for a
leaked argument with an uber driver in
this argument the uber driver would
question travis about recent changes to
uber black which seemed unfair to
apparently uber had reduced uber black
fears substantially which made it
unprofitable for the driver to continue
driving around with a 97 000 car
at first the two would address the
problem diplomatically but it didn't
take long for things to get out of hand
how much is the mile now 275 you know
what what some people
don't like to take
responsibility for that
they blame everything
good luck good luck to you too but i
know you don't gonna go far
travis's comment that the uber driver
wasn't taking responsibility for his own
actions attracted a lot of criticism
people were quick to call out how travis
had bypassed loads of taxi regulations
and labor lost through uber and how he
was not taking responsibility for any of
that now honestly i think some of the
blame does lie on the uber driver as
well given that buying a 97 000 car
based on uber income is not exactly the
smartest of choices but that's besides
the point travis's allegations and the
comments had destroyed his reputation
and this was enough to kick off the
delete uber movement travis would
eventually be ousted by the board and he
would leave the company altogether and
sell all of his talk in december of 2019
but the damage had already been done
despite all these challenges it does
look like uber is finally turning a
corner they've already expanded all
across the globe so they no longer have
to fight so hard for market share they
have also expanded into adjacent
businesses like food delivery which has
diversified their income on top of this
they've cut losses on self-driving and
travis is no longer involved in the
company whatsoever so it really is just
a matter of leaning up the business and
achieving profitability something else
to note is the vast majority of the
losses last quarter were due to poorly
performing assets as opposed to terrible
cash flow if we take a look at their
ebitda we'll see that uber only lost 250
million last quarter due to the business
itself something that is a bit
concerning is their ebitda has actually
never been positive but fortunately
their revenue and gross profits are at
all-time highs so uber may just need a
couple more quarters to achieve
consistent profitability in fact many
analysts are speculating that 2022 will
be uber's final negative year and that
they'll be consistently breaking even by
the end of 2023
now of course it'll take a couple of
years from there to really build up
profitability but it does seem like uber
can pull in respectable profits by the
end of this decade however this does not
mean that uber is completely out of the
woods because they still have to go up
against tesla it's no secret that tesla
wants to get into the right healing
business with self-driving cars and
though elon's timelines are almost
always too ambitious it seems like
whether it happens in 2025 or 2030 or
2040 tesla will likely be the first one
to achieve fully autonomous cars and
once tesla starts releasing these cars
onto the road things will get quite
challenging for uber either they can buy
teslas themselves or they can continue
keeping up their partnerships with
autonomous companies like aurora but
neither of these are exactly optimal
tesla will always be able to offer
cheaper ride healing services than uber
buying teslas and then putting them on
the road conversely it's also not clear
how well uber self-driving partnerships
will pan out compared to tesla's
offerings so the long-term future of
uber is still rather uncertain but the
next three to five years should
hopefully be smooth as uber finally
achieves profitability but that's just
what i think do you guys ride ubers
comment that down below also drop a like
if you would like to eat the
responsibility of growing this channel
and of course consider checking out our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing and
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you